I love the scenes between
Lisey and her sisters because
I tried to capture some of
that sibling rivalry dynamic.
To me, it’s funny and it’s touching
that the way we are as children
with our brothers and sisters
kind of lasts into adulthood.
Julianne, Jennifer, and Joan catch
that feeling of real sisterhood.
To me, those are my favorite scenes.
Something that is so well constructed
by Stephen is these three sisters,
how Lisey, Darla, and Amanda, they
are so different from each other,
how they love and protect each other.
The core close relationship
of the sisters is pretty
central to the whole piece.
They have a quirky, funny,
combative style between them.
Like all families, I think
they understand each other
and as the episodes go on they
really become more and more
united as a team in their
efforts to protect Lisey.
Lisey loves her sisters very
much and when her sister
needs help she starts to remember
things that happened to her
and starts to realize that there’s
a way that she can help her sister.